how are you a crunchy crackle my Kringle
all right all right all right you're
just you're such an oddball
let me start when you put that face up
of those two mine Wow does I need a
salad guard for your face I do want to
say I think you're looking good in the
past sometimes a little dodgy but I
think you look good now
well thanks I'm modeling again you're
modeling okay you're gonna laugh maybe
this isn't the forum for me you know I
got Fashion Week in Milan last week you
did not what are you talking about well
logged guy you want to see my modeling
pictures no roll those Henry and I don't
want to see this there's no one here
named Dolce and Gabbana boy right yeah
that's just that's really stupid yeah
these are so poorly made you know what's
tough with the angel wings I like to
camp yeah cap at all I don't really go
camping much no you ever try to stuff
into a Walmart sleeping bag with angel
wings now never have good for
crop-dusting - all right let me tell you
something I'm told nothing you've said
so far has made any sense
you